radical republican congressman matt  gates is jumping on the christian  nationalism bandwagon and he says he  supports school prayer well  uh christian nationalism aside it's just  not constitutional at least as far as  public schools are concerned the  constitution guarantees no establishment  of religion that means both not  establishing  religion over non-religion and not  establishing one religion over another  and if there is official school prayer  you can't really have it for every  religion out there and by definition you  would be establishing it over  non-religion and you would be picking at  least one or more religions and  establishing those over others so matt  gates claims to love the constitution  but he very quickly puts it in the trash  or the toilet trump's favorite place  when he doesn't like where it points